i export a lot of options
i wrote many articles to my friends
talked to them
and i realized it sort of needed to be a
cultural change sort of need to be
bottom up
grassroots um something i knew
the energy was there because you just
look at
the most recent institutional assessment
from yale this was
basically the number one thing that
students faculty and alumni all pointed
to
to the administration was cultivating
more conversations on campus and more
difficult conversations on campus
so the people on campus know it um
and you look at a gallup poll 61
of students are on ivy league campuses
afraid to
speak their minds because of the campus
culture um
the campus culture is causing a sort of
freezing effect on discourse
can you pause on that again so what
percentage of students feel afraid to
speak their mind
61 nationally and you're talking about
you know
places nothing like uh the ivy league
where i'd say
i'd imagine it would be even worse
because of
just the way that these communities kind
of come about and the sorts of
people who are attracted or are invited
to these sorts of communities
that's nationwide that college students
and it's going up
that college students are afraid to say
what they believe
because of their campus climate so it's
a maturity
it's not it's not a conservative thing
it's not a liberal thing
it's a group thing we're all feeling it
the majority of us are feeling it and
basically just
it doesn't even you don't even
necessarily
need to have anything to say you just
have a fear
that's right so when you're like
teaching
[Music]
you know metaphors a really powerful
thing to explain
you know and there's just the caution
that you feel that's just horrible for
humor
now comedians have the freedom to just
talk [ __ ] which is why i really
appreciate
uh somebody's been a friend recently tim
dillon who has
who gives zero uh pardon my french fox
about anything which is very liberating
very important person to just
tear down the powerful but you know
inside the the academia as an educator
as a teacher as a professor
you don't have the same freedom so that
fear is felt i guess by a majority of
students it's
um and you're getting something there
too which is that
um if you're afraid to speak
metaphorically if you're
afraid to speak imprecisely it can be
very difficult
to actually think at all and to think to
the extremities of what you're capable
of
because these are the these are the
mechanisms we use when we don't have
quite the precise
mathematical language to quite pinpoint
what we're talking about yet this is the
beginning this is the creative step that
leads to new knowledge
and so that really scares me is that if
i'm not allowed to sort of excavate
these things these ideas with people
in the sort of messy sloppy way that we
do as humans when we're first being
creative
are we how are we going to be able to
continue to innovate are we going to
continue to be able to learn
that's what really starts to scare me
you